et salue aujourd'hui on est à
vert-saint-denis on est on est où
exactement
cette année c'est un et je suis en train
de tourner je suis à la salle de la
citrouille en fait la citrouille ici
c'est une très jolie salle
j'avais quoi philippe roche en première
partie et j'ai surtout de nouveaux potes
avec moi qui s'appelle j'ai six enfants
tel geste y aient accès et axel en
répondant par me parle
est ce que tu penses que je peux
connaître la date de naissance peut-être
non évidemment
non je suis donc est ce que je veux
connaître votre signe astrologique non
plus aucun signe astrologique en est
donc si je le trouvais sur l'un de vous
deux j'aurais une chance sur deux
d'avoir si je le trouve sur les deux en
même temps j'avais j'avais une chance
sur 24
et c'est ça que j'ai essayé de faire
plonger c'est clair il ne peut pas peur
il ya deux ans je ne peux pas connaître
votre signe astrologique mais je vais
essayer de le trouver
deux techniques différentes on va
commencer avec que toi j'ai si le
prendre ton poignet ce qui s'appelle
duclair monisme dans ta tête que par oui
ou par non
mais uniquement dans la tête hier ne
cherche pas à me donner la nasa envisage
qu'est ce je n'aime pas trop regarder je
vous regarde et dit tu me réponds pas
vraiment dans ta tête tu es né dans le
début d'année tu es né dans le milieu
d'année tu es né de la fin de l'année
autour mois chauds du toit crois tu es
fier de son signe astrologique ne vont
pas forcément fière de son signe
astrologique
toutes les réponses de ces deux
questions la surcharge et si oui ok j'ai
une petite idée de l'écrire ici est
comme ça que vous rêvez laver les deux
en même temps ça marche je pose aussi
des questions à 3,6 litres ou joe boyd a
vomi par tout ça et ça pour moi j'étais
si leur manteau ça va être différent
je vais dire tous les signes
astrologiques pas forcément toussaint
tout ce que je veux dans l'or que je
veux quand tu entretiens dans ta tête tu
dis stop
mais dans la tête tu cherches pas à
laisser transparaître accord par exemple
tu peux être capricorne qui pèse s'agit
d'air qui peut être dupe lès lyon tu
peux être quoi sont dues petit scorpion
tu peux être l'union qui peut être
boisson m fillon
scorpion
je vous le disiez que j'écris c'est
celui que je pense que tu es celle ci
est le deuxième que j'écris c'est celui
pour axel celui du par geci est ce que
tu peux me dire son signe astrologique
de poissons et axel la viande poisson
lugnorre poisson bio liens profonds et
lyon vont chanter comme millions merci
merci de m'avoir suivi
n'oubliez pas de vous abonner à la
chaîne si vous pouvez prendre le temps
s'écoule ça m'aide beaucoup
rendez vous le 28 mars pour les
hallucinations collectives et au mois
d'avril débuts avec jeu sera mieux vous
à l'entrepôt de théâtre venez s'écoule
comme ça on fait des vidéos à voir le
spectacle ça j'aime bien merci vous
rendez vous demain à 17 heures pour le
prochain mentale l'ocha